c'est un monde où l'homme apprend à se
faire tout petit dans les grottes d'azé
on part à la recherche de l'histoire
avec un grand h
une histoire enfouie sous terre qu'il
faut creuser pour enfin la trouver ou
bien essayé de descendre à plat voilà
tout ce que toute la terre que tu l'as
où tu es genou l'a foutu tournon toi
c'est pas facile parce que la niche est
étroite
il faut essayer de deux tours am2 pour
ramener sous les coups de pinceau les
ossements se dévoile peu à peu
il s'agit du squelette d'un ours vieux
de 250 millions là c'est très rare parce
qu'on tombe dessus et quelqu'un était
venu dans cette boîte ya quelques années
en arrière en disant il n'y a rien à
faire dans cette voie très y en a trop
mais est en fait si c'est le cinquième
que l'on trouve dans toutes la grotte
donc depuis plus de 50 ans qu'il ya des
fouilles et du coup on ne dégage très
patiemment très vraiment enfouis pour
faire les plans du squelette pour
étudier toutes les pièces qui sont
encore présentes en connexion et puis
étudier dans quelle condition mais elle
s'est déposé ici et qu'est ce qui a
permis sa conservation des trésors comme
celui ci les spéléologues n'en trouve
que rarement au cours de leur lente
avancée
trois cents sont remplis puis vidé à
chaque descente
il ne progresse que de 80 précieux
centimètres creusent et sortir les sauts
brouette au fond et on vide
envie de découvrir même à découvrir
d'autres galeries d'autres galeries
vides qu'on puisse continuer à aller
encore plus aller encore plus loin vers
un ailleurs pour l'instant inconnues
pour espérer aux experts ça trouver
quelque chose de vie de se trouver une
salle on ne sait pas du tout c'est aussi
ce qui fait le piment de venir ici c'est
que chaque dimanche quand on vit à
creuser on dit on va trouver quelque
chose ont toujours quelque chose qui
nous motive pour revenir le dimanche
suivant
au fur et à mesure des découvertes
l'histoire d'azé s'écrivent la grotte
omis l'ours est loin d'avoir dévoilé
tous ses secrets